bonsoir jacques myard merci d'être avec
nous en direct sur rt france alors vous
faisiez vous partie des maires
signataires d'une tribune pour demander
de repousser la réouverture des écoles à
une date ultérieure est ce que le
président vous a rassuré ce matin
écoutez premièrement le président a
visité une section une école où
véritablement des professeurs
accueillent des enfants de soignants
nous avons tous ce genre d'expérience et
nous savons tous que lass c'est
parfaitement gérable parce que c'est un
tout petit effectif
une dizaine d'enfants et on ne peut pas
généraliser ça c'est là où il ya un
problème parce qu'on nous a montré
effectivement un président en bavardant
avec des enfances lavant les mains et
interrogeant les enfants ça c'est
d'accord mais ça ne correspond pas à la
réalité de l'ouverture massive des
écoles et c'est là où il ya un problème
c'est qu'en réalité on voit très bien
que si on veut véritablement recevoir
tous les enfants et on nous a donné un
ordre de priorité ce sont des enfants
des soignants ce sont les enfants de la
poste ce sont les enfants qui sont en
retard scolaire et là on voit bien qu'on
bute sur véritablement des mesures
sanitaires qui sont extrêmement
draconiennes où la notion de groupe doit
être la notion où on a quinze enfants et
ne peut pas se mélanger
lorsque le président vient d'exploser à
l'instant qu'on va faire rentrer
d'autres personnes et cetera
il n'en demeure pas moins que cette
notion de groupe d'une quinzaine
d'enfants qui doit être là même toute la
journée
pose de multiples problèmes
d'organisation et c'est en cela que
véritablement on ne peut pas se tromper
alors je tenir à pardonner mans vannes
et dans le détail on va découvrir à
l'écran peut-être ces quelques mesures
et les 63 pages en sont ce protocole
sanitaire
parmi les plus importantes on le voit en
quête mètres carrés disponibles pour
chaque élève des masques obligatoire
pour les enseignants de maternelle
notamment repas pris à la cantine 2
préférence distance d'un mètre entre les
élèves
on classe ou dans les couloirs c'est
cela ce sont ces mesures qui nous semble
extrêmement contraignantes voire
impossible à mettre en oeuvre dans
certaines écoles alors qu il est bien
évident lorsque vous a intéressé à des
enfants qui ont je dirais six sept huit
ans ça va être extrêmement complexe
parce que les enfants il ya un moment il
explose
voyez ce que je veux dire et d'ailleurs
dans la visite du président de la
république nous avons vu deux enfants
qui étaient très proches les uns des
autres et qui se tapent hôtel un an sur
l'autre
donc on voit bien que cette gymnastique
ces mesures barrières elles sont
extrêmement difficile à mettre en oeuvre
à ce stade et c'est la raison pour
laquelle nous sommes un certain nombre d
attention ce n'est pas jouable
ensuite on a parlé des études dirigées
qui est ce qui va les faire parce que le
problème il est là c'est qu'un enfant
s'ils rentrent le matin vers 8h30 9h et
qui restent jusqu'à 19 heures parce
qu'il faut que les parents travaillent
il est évident que ce titre les corps
enseignant ne va pas être capable
véritablement de dispenser son savoir
pendant cette longue durée et on risque
de faire appel à ce que nous appelons
les animateurs des centres de loisirs et
c'est bien évidemment une charge énorme
je dis bien énorme pour les communes
voir les parents donc on est dans une
situation où il faut ré ouvrir les
écoles je suis d'accord il faut pas
remettre la france au travail mais on
voit très bien aujourd'hui que
l'ensemble des mesures barrières qu'on
veut nous imposer et notamment à travers
cette notion de groupe avant les choses
quasiment là jacques myard tout de même
emmanuel macron affirme qu'il n'y aura
pas de contrainte ni pour les mères qui
refuse d'ouvrir ni pour les enseignants
qui ne souhaitent pas reprendre des
précise plutôt une bonne rentrée qu'une
rentrée en nombre ça laisse tout de même
une marge de manoeuvre non oui bien
évidemment mais vous allez avoir la
pression des parents et puis pour
l'instant sont sur la base du
volontariat il ne souhaite pas tous les
trois leurs enfants vous avez aussi un
autre facteur est ce que les professeurs
vont pouvoir accepter ses conditions
or c'est là où il y a
m car nice nous avec eux il ya un
système dual bien sûr les mairies
mettent à disposition d'un certain
nombre de moyens matériels mais il y a
le corps préfectoral qui a son mot à
dire
donc l'adéquation des deux n'est pas
toujours évidente
donc je crois que effectivement il va
avoir un peu plus de temps c'est évident
il faut y aller progressivement
là je suis d'accord mais il ne faut pas
se leurrer on n'a pas trouvé encore la
pierre philosophale pour résoudre tout
ça alors jacques myard il y avait un
autre point qui chagrinait les mères
c'est celui de la responsabilité en bref
c'est un enfant tombe malade il peut
peut-être poursuivre le maire de sa
commune en tout cas c'est la craindre la
quille qui flotte sur ce point emmanuel
macron dit on ne doit pas donner le
sentiment qu'il y aurait une amnistie
pour les élus je pense qu'il vous faut
préciser la loi bien cadrer les choses
je ne veux pas que les maires soient
menacés ou inquiété au delà de leurs
propres responsabilités s'avoue
satisfait cette réponse un petit peu et
fuse protêt que ça ne dépend ni du
président de la république a ni
l'éducation nationale mais in fine et du
juge
et c'est là où effectivement il ya pas
mal d'interrogations
ce qui est clair c'est que le maire il
fait le maximum
il a pas véritablement une obligation de
résultat une obligation de moyens tout
mettre en oeuvre et éviter effectivement
la faute intentionnelle
s'il se rend compte que véritablement
c'est impossible
s'il se rend compte qu'il est en train
de mettre des enfants en danger
là il doit absolument arrêter le système
et ne pas poursuivre je suis pas trop je
dirais inquiet à ce titre mais il est
vrai qu'on peut avoir de multiples
ensuite procédure parce que vous savez
très bien que cela dépend de chacun de
faire un procès et vous trouverez
toujours des hommes de loi pour dire on
va y aller on ne sait jamais on peut
gagner mais il n'en demeure pas moins
que la responsabilité des élus est
totale j'ai dit un jour que nous étions
tous du gibier de mise en examen
et bien c'est possible mais il n'en
demeure pas moins que nous sommes aussi
des gens responsables et nous sommes
capables de faire face
l'arrière
et et c'est que de toute façon nous
sommes obligés de vivre
nous sommes obligés de réouvrir les
écoles mais qu'on nous donne un peu de
temps qu'on nous donne aussi des normes
qui soit plus acceptable et qu'on nous
laisse travailler
ça prendra du temps ce sera parfait
demain matin merci beaucoup jacques
myard d'avoir été en direct sur rt
france alors